so that's all the traveling I've done
you've done any traveling recently
Raleigh Mal
I
yes sir have you um done any traveling
recently brother
ah no I'm I'm about to
okay great and where are you headed bud
I'm going to Denver oh okay buddy wow
and how do you do without how to
how do
um
I'm allowed to say this how do are you
do a lot of uh how do Asians do at
altitude
uh I I think we do I think we do good
okay
what are some famous high altitude
Asians are there any I'm trying to think
of one because if I think of a mountain
brother I don't always think of
um
and maybe this is racist I mean I don't
think of an Asian on a mountain
is that
um yeah so I looked it up it says
tibitions and Sherpa are the only two
present day high altitude East Asian
ethnic groups tabitions damn
I thought I thought damn tabitions
are you tabishian wow and those are high
altitude Asians huh
correct gosh boy some Red Bull drinkers
baby they're getting up there and what
else has been going on in your life
brother
um nothing much
um a good friend of mine passed
no
yeah oh man
but I'm sorry man um
and was it a uh was it a male or female
uh female oh
God that's what usually I feel like men
die more I don't feel like I hear a lot
about women dying
you know
oh I'm sorry man
were you able to go to a service or
anything or what do you guys do for that
sort of thing
yeah we had a uh a good uh celebration
of life on Saturday
[Music]
and was there food or not there was yeah
um
what would they have
they had uh tacos oh
that's interesting I feel like you don't
see a lot of um
talk you know a lot of
I I feel like you don't see a lot of
like kind of tacos when there is uh
deceased
or death you know dang that's surprising
were you surprised at that
um not really she she really liked tacos
oh man
we're gonna check back in with you you
know I know we haven't seen each other
in a while and I see you got that facial
hair going maybe you got that catfish
rocking huh Daddy I do how do you feel
about that what what spurned that
oh I just wanted to try something new
hmm
and do you feel different with it does
it feel how does that feel you know
because I rock it you know
yeah no it feels great feels definitely
uh very different like Hal
like do you feel give me five words that
makes you feel
some you know
give me some words
I feel older okay older
grown grown okay so black and older
[Music]
um
I don't know I look better maybe that's
hold on that's a lot of what you don't
just do you just have to do a word sorry
but I have to have the rules for the
little thing for the game
you want to think about them yeah I'll
think about them okay
what else Riley I'm sure people are
going to want to know we usually get an
update on how your dating life is going
what's going on there bub
uh still
nothing really
okay that's okay well damn dude and
how's everything going I know we talked
in the past about the masturbatory
efforts and stuff you've been out there
glazing that Glizzy homie what's been
going on you've been freaking burping
that little pants yurt or what
um you've been frisbeeing that little
syrup dog or what
ah still nothing
can you tell Raleigh Mal people are not
believing this man that you've never you
still have never ejaculated is that true
yeah it's true
brother we gotta get you on a damn
pay-per-view
I mean you could open up for Logan Paul
and Dylan Dennis you could be in an
early preliminary I mean there's never
in your life
you telling me the truth Riley I am
never not even in your sleep God has
never come and touched you in your sleep
never
oh my God we could raffle you off to a
bunch of older gay men in Hollywood they
bro they pay half a million dollars for
you in Hollywood to be getting clean
sauce out of a damn Vietnamese fella
from the mountains
yeah um I'm I'm actually not Vietnamese
well but yeah but you know what I'm or
what are you
I'm uh Japanese Korean Hawaiian and
Norwegian
well you know that's pretty much
Vietnamese dude but that doesn't matter
man what matters is we're both
human beings baby boy and I can't
believe boy you got that clean syrup in
your son you got that six thousand
octane boy gosh that's God's Gleek homie
you that thing coming right off the
clouds of the Lord
my God
dude if you you if you've got you a law
if you got you a half ounce of that
and you uh
painted the toes of some of these gay
men and perverted men out there in
Hollywood my God
oh but I'm sorry that's not what we need
to be doing that's not what we need to
be involved in man I'm sorry for saying
that stuff
oh you're good you know but why do you
worry about not being able to get an
erection when you do get a woman Riley
when you because you're now you're
saving yourself for marriage that's
correct correct but how do you know your
that your body's gonna work then
I I just believe it will when the time
comes dang boy
wow bro
that is a risk though Riley look I but
you know what man I've seen miracles
happen man I really have
seen miracles happen bro
and if you look I would stand by y'all's
bed and pray for y'all pray
you know by y'all's marital bed or
whatever be in the next room and you
know put my hands on the wall and pray
or whatever you needed buddy and what
type of gallery do you change your
stance on what type of girl you're
looking for like say if you had to pick
a word or something that like what would
your gal kind of look like you think or
how is she or if you have some thoughts
on her what her heart is like or
whatever
um I don't know
um blonde okay okay you like a blonde
okay
and if I tell you two names like Bambi
or
um
Rebecca does one of those names sit
better with you what type of gal you're
thinking
uh
not really
okay either one
now Bambi they die in the woods you know
what I'm saying so you gotta keep that
on tap buddy on your
you know you gotta have you ever done
any door-to-door sales Riley
I have really
wonderful man what did you guys sell
um anything from popcorn to
See's Candy
oh wow and how'd you get involved with
that you said you were doing more um is
that called uh
that's not really on trays that's more
side items huh right okay
and what uh wait how do you get involved
with that
uh popcorn was for Scouts and See's
Candy was for band
and what was easier to Pedal let me what
do you think was easier to Pedal out
there
what do you mean like a bite no no what
was easier to sell to folks oh
um See's Candy oh yeah why you think
I think everyone just liked candy more
than popcorn yeah
yeah that's interesting yeah I think if
you put candy on the word of on the back
of anything it's you know people are
interested in it
you know you throw any you throw candy
on the back of something people are more
excited you know anything else you want
to say Riley
um you know just that you know I'm glad
that my family is safe
um my I have some family out in Maui
um some cousins out there that they're
both firefighters and you know I'm glad
everyone's safe really huh firefighters
so were they were they they must have
been involved huh yes uh they all lost
their homes oh man
oh
[Music]
man the world the sometimes there's just
so much going on it feels it feels just
really it feels like a lot doesn't it
yeah definitely well I'm sorry brother
I'm sorry that that happened for them
and you know that that community over
there God there is nothing more special
if you get to witness it in your life
um I'm sorry that that happened but
thank you for letting us know that Riley
to let you know let us know a little bit
more about you you know
and that's important and if we ever get
that boner to launch I mean we might
have to get a couple firemen to put that
thing Out Boy
whoo boy we gonna get that Branch to
burn
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one